I want to end this
section on computability,
by revisiting the scene we used
at the beginning of the course.
Where the teacher was explaining
functions in terms of ordered pairs, and
the students were thinking of what
they had to do to X in order to get Y.
The promise of our study of
computability was to better appreciate
the difference between
these understandings.
And I hope you will agree
that we have achieved that.
We've seen how there are many
functions that are not computable
in any ordinary sense of the word,
by counting argument.
We made precise what we meant by
computation, going all the way
back to Turing's inspiration from
his own experience with pen and
paper, to formalize the Turing machine.
And we argued for the Church Turing
thesis, that this model can compute
anything that a computer today, or
any one envisioned for tomorrow can.
Lastly, we described a whole
family of uncomputable functions
through Rice's theorem.
What's next in the study
of computability?
Let's ask Lance.